«Мама мила раму».
Це не лише вправа з читання із радянського букваря,
а свідоцтво тотальної гендерної дискримінації тих часів
І схоже, що цей образ настільки міцно закріпився,
що автори сучасних шкільних підручників
підсвідомо продовжують його ретранслювати,
каже експертка з гендерних питань Олена Малахова.
«Ми можемо ось так провести вертикальну лінію.
І в нас утворюються два світи.
Один світ-відпочиває –
тато, дідусь і хлопчик.
Один світ - бабуся і  дівчинки - читають, в’яжуть
Мама взагалі винесена. Мама виконує виключно обслуговуючу функцію».
В останні 2-3 роки гендерна реформа, яка охопила й освіту,
поволі ламає стереотипи минулого.
Поки найбільш гендерно збалансовані - підручники для початкової школи.
«Немає однобокого висвітлення
жінок чи чоловіків з будь-якого приводу їх суспільного життя,
виховання дітей, рівності.
Всі твори, які є в читанні, чи в чудових  теперішніх хрестоматіях,
там взагалі такого питання не прослідковується».
Вчителі та вчительки, які пройшли відповідну підготовку,
вміють надягати так звані «гендерні окуляри»
і поступово змінювати світогляд дітей.
І ось результат. В школах нарешті з’явилися не лише учні, а й учениці.
І до них звертаються вже не в множині чоловічого роду.
Їх також вчать бути ввічливими «по-сучасному»
і казати не директор, а директорка, не вчитель, а вчителька.
Поступово збільшується і кількість навчальних матеріалів,
виконаних за правилами гендерної рівності.
Хоча ще кілька років тому головним героєм подібних ілюстрацій
міг бути виключно хлопчик, ніби комп’ютери для дівчат не існували.
Цього року Україна ухвалила Державну програму
забезпечення рівних можливостей чоловіків і жінок.
Олена Малахова каже, після Майдану було набагато простіше домогтися від Міносовіти
гендерної експертизи підручників та виправлення помилок.
А от із видавництвами - куди складніше.
«Більшість із них сприйняли рекомендації експертизи
як певну нападку на них. Як свідчення того, що їх підручники неякісні.
Це неправда. Ми хотіли донести,
що ми всі - продукт того суспільства,  в якому живемо.
Дорослі люди не могли інакше побудувати підручник,
тільки тому що в них самих є ці стереотипи».
Тато, який виховує власних дітей.
Мама, яка вже не миє раму, а, приміром, рухає вперед науку чи виголошує промову в парламенті.
Видавництва потроху починають працювати у «гендерних окулярах».
І цей процес має значно прискоритися цього року, вважає експертка Малахова.
Міносвіти планує, що за державні кошти
не буде надруковано жоден підручник,
якій містить ознаки гендерної дискримінації.